مرحبا نايف كان هذا صباح اليوم بالفعل في
صبيحه هذا اليوم لكن الان وفي الثلاث
ساعات الماضيه هناك هدوء نسبي وهناك حركه
للمواطنين واضحه كذلك ليست طبيعيه بالكامل
لكنها شبه طبيعيه في مناطق متفرقه
وايضا بدات او بدا المواطنين للخروج لقضاء
احتياجياتهم منذ ان هدات هذه الاحوال في
الصباح اليوم ايضا سمعنا بعض اطلاق الرصاص
وكذلك دليل المدافع منذ الصباح لكن بعد
ذلك هدات هذه الاوضاع نسبيا والان كما
تشاهد الوضع شبه طبيعي هنا في العاصمه
الخرطوم وفي شرقيها بالتحديد في بقيه
المناطق تجددت الاشتباكات في مناطق محدوده
هي منطقه الفتحات ايضا محيط لذاعه
والتلفزيون سمعت اصوات للرصاص وكذلك في
منطقه الصالحه جنوب غرب ام درمان ربما هذه
الابرز في النقاط التي تجددت فيها
الاشتباكات بالنسبه للحركه لحركه تبدو شبه
طبيعيه هناك محل تجاريه بدات بالع بالفعل
في هذه المنطقه وكذلك افران الخبز ايضا من
هنا من غير بعيد من هذه المنطقه شاهدنا
واحده من المحطات التي كانت تشهد وصول
النازحين الذين يريدون الخروج من ولايه
الخرطوم الى الولايات مختلفه كانت هذه
المحطه دائما مزدحمه يبحث فيها الركاب عن
الحافلات للخروج من الولايه في الولايات
الشرقيه والجنوبيه اليوم ايضا شهدت عدم
اقبال واضح من المواطنين الحافلات موجوده
لكنها لا تجد ركابا ليخرجوا من الولايه
ربما لان هنالك هذا الهدوء دفع المواطنين
الى عدم الخروج من الولايه او ربما من
كانوا قد نووا الخروج من الولايه قد خرجوا
بالفعل وهل كان هناك تدفق كبير خلال
الايام الماضيه سالم حسب ما رصدت انت على
الارض
نعم كان هنالك تدفق كبير في هذه المناطق
او في هذه المحطات التي يخرج منها
المواطنين الى ولايات مجاوره كان تدفق
كبير جدا نشاهد اليوم هدوء في هذا الامر
او قله مقارنه بالايام الماضيه ايضا
التحسن اليوم في ان الامر يعني تدريجيا في
هذه الهدنه من هدنه الى هدنه هناك تدرج من
كل هدنه لاخرى بان هناك تحسن في الاوضاع
هناك يعني قله او فترات زمنيه قصيره
للاشتباكات نفسها كذلك الحركه باتت اقرب
الى الطبيعيه كل هذا التحسن ربما يدعو الى
التفاؤل في مساله ان الهدن او الهدنات
يزداد تحسنها يوما بعد اخر طيب فيما يخص
الوضع الانساني ايضا والصحي في العاصمه
الخرطوم كيف يمكن وصفه حتى هذه اللحظه
سهله
بالنسبه للوضع الانساني حقيقه الشكاوى من
المواطنين من تدفق المواد الغذائيه وتدفق
المحروقات كذلك بالنسبه لمحطات الوقود هذه
واحده من الشكاوى يضاف اليها الشكاوى
الامنيه او المشكله الامنيه وهي مشكله
واضحه ومعروفه خاصه بعد عمليات النهب
والسرقه كانت الشرطه السودانيه بالامس قد
اعلنتها واوضحت ان قوات الاحتياط المركزي
ستبدا عملها في تامين الممتلكات
والمواطنين بعد ذلك جاء بيان الجيش محدثا
عن هذه يتحدث عن هذه النقطه نقطه الشرطه
وان هذه العمليات ستكون بالتدريج بالنسبه
لنزول الشرطه للشوارع لكن بالنسبه
للعمليات الانسانيه يحتاج المواطنون فيما
يتعلق بالمستشفيات الى مزيد من التامين
للكوادر الطبيه للوصول الى المستشفيات
وكذلك وصول الموده اللوجستيه او المعينات
اللازمه لعمل هذه المستشفيات المستشفيات
الخارجه عن العمل ايضا تحتاج الى مجهود
لان تعود الى العمل في حال الحاجه لها
خاصه موضوع الطوارئ والاصحابات وكذلك
الحالات التي تتعلق بغسيل الكلى وغيرها
وحتى العمليات كل هذه الامور تحتاج الى
مراجعات كبيره جدا في بالنسبه لما يتعلق
بالامور الطبيه الامور الاخرى المعينات
الغذائيه تحتاج ايضا الى تدفق كل هذا
الامر يرتبط بهدنه
تلتزم فيها الاطراف بمسارات امنه تستطيع
بعد ذلك المساعدات الانسانيه او حتى
المعينات اللوجستيه بالوصول الى مناطق
السكر ماذا عن توفر هذه المعينات حاليا
اتحدث عن
الادويه في المقام الاول عن الغذاء ايضا
كذلك عن مياه الشرب ايضا
سالم والتي يعني دار الكثير من الحديث
حولها وربما مقاطع الفيديو التي سربت لبيع
اساسا المياه غير الصالحه للشرب باسعار
كبيره جدا
مشكله مياه الشوربه اكبر مدينه تعاني منها
هي مدينه بحري لان احياء كثيره جدا من
مدينه بحري تعاني من قطاع تام لمياه الشرب
منذ بدا هذه الازمه دخلنا في اسبوعين
الثالثه الان حتى هذه اللحظه ولا قطره ماء
واحده في احياء كثيره جدا من مدينه بحري
وهذا من الامور المؤسفه تلتحق بها بعد ذلك
حيث صالحه وهو في ام درمان في اقصى جنوب
ام درمان بعد ذلك بعض الاحيان في ام درمان
وبعض الاحياء في الخرطوم وفي وسط الخرطوم
كذلك مشكله المياه مشكله
بالفعل هي
مزعجه ومقلقه كذلك لان ابعادها كذلك في
عدم شرب المياه النقيه بعد ذلك الى امراض
الى غير ذلك مما حذرت منه منظمه الصحه
العالميه في احد بياناتها لكن المهمه الان
هو ان يتم تدارك هذا الامر بالرجوع هذه
المحطات للعمل وما زال المواطنين يطالبون
بذلك كانت ولايه الخرطوم قبل اسبوع او
اكثر قد وعدت باصلاح محطات المياه لكنها
بعد ذلك قالت انه يحتاج وتفاصيل كثيره
تتعلق بهذا الامر اما فيما يتعلق
بالمعينات الغذائيه كل هذا الامر يرتبط
بفتح الطرق اولا ووصول هذه المساعدات لانه
غالبيه الجسور الان خارج الخدمه عدا جسور
محدوده جدا التي يستطيع ان يمر بها
المواطنون يضاف الى ذلك ان العديد من هذه
الطرق يتعرض فيها المواطنون لمضايقات من
القوات المنتشره والتي تحمل انواع من
الاسلحه الكثيره جدا كل هذه الامور مرتبطه
مع بعضها البعض من الخرطوم راسله العربيه
سالم الهاشمي شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل لمتابعه
المزيد لقناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات